everyone welcome to the corridor cast my
name is Ren and today we have a very
special guest by the name of Tom Scott
from the YouTube channel Tom Scott he
likes to wear red shirts and talk about
things you might not know for instance
in today's podcast we're gonna talk
about a lot of that stuff like his
experiences flying with the Royal Air
Force and changing gravity to what AI
has in store for us futurology all that
stuff whether we should be scared or not
yeah lots of other things like being a
pirate stay tuned and let's get to it
hello welcome to the podcast
oh yes I'm really excited to have you
here we actually recently hung out just
a couple weeks ago at think economist
yeah Destin from smarter every day ran
ran think on and yeah that was a good
place to hang out for a while that was a
lot of fun was that your first time in
Alabama first time holla but um you know
I think I might have been through it I
might have been through a little bit of
it before yeah I did Alabama have a
coastline is it yes then yes I have on a
road trip between Dole and Oh Florida
okay we literally skipped through we did
the whole thing in 12 hours so somehow
alright this is this is unnecessary
fluff you can cut frankly but there you
go
yeah so I used to live in Louisiana and
we would drive over to Pensacola and
that would mean that I would drive
through Alabama I think we went through
Birmingham but I'd never actually spent
time in Alabama before I was surprised
Huntsville is strange because it's
Rocket City is it's where all the rocket
engineers for NASA ended up so it's this
little island of Science and Technology
in the middle of Alabama which it does I
haven't seen the restaurant Bama does
have the best reputation know for
science me technology has a reputation
in general for a reason and I can't
neither confirm or deny any of those
reputations but ya know I was really
surprised by how just scientific
everything was in Huntsville like you
show up and all of a sudden you see this
giant rocket just standing like this
monolith in the sky that you can pretty
much see from anywhere and that was the
first time I'd ever seen a Saturn 5
rocket that's the the rocket that took
us to the moon yeah I'm just driving
through cuz I went from there to a
couple other places if you if you just
drive through you just find yourself on
this massive aerospace science park
where yeah just companies with their
dramatic logos with other arrowheads in
them this can all over the place
okay bayaud they had developing Rockets
here so did you did you enjoy I think
akan you think you'll go back next year
if it's a if it happening again
I will absolutely go back because
obvious there was a there was a public
event and then there was space for the
folks who were invited like yourself
there's like what like a couple hundred
people that you invited a couple days
ahead I was no space for us to hang out
and that was wonderful yeah I I in it
there's one night we're hanging out and
we're hanging out with Mark Rover and
and Diana from physics girl yes over and
was like facetiming someone else and I
just like I had to just take a step back
I step back I was seating she didn't so
I just took a step back and it just took
a photo of that I was like this is great
like all my favorite people in one place
yeah no thicker cone was really cool do
you think you learned anything from like
some of the sessions that we did I think
so yeah there was a lot of there's a lot
of crosstalk I mean what you had to make
sure was that the folks who did YouTube
didn't take over the conversation yeah I
think one of the sessions I was in we
had to ban the word algorithm really
okay because half of the folks there are
youtubers but the other half are our
authors or librarians or like anyone
putting out something in any medium and
so the youtubers had a tendency to to
froth like we just talked about our work
and art and everything else yeah the
exclusion of the folks whose whose lives
and yeah I think we both did a session
I'm like growing an audience and it was
like half like you said half the artists
that they they do podcast they write
blogs and they're like we don't care
about your strategies for how to gain an
audience through YouTube so we ended up
just splitting the whole group into two
two groups yeah uh I took a lot of
inspiration from that trip and I'm gonna
apply that going forward into a lot of
our videos haha yeah so speaking on
videos you've been around on YouTube for
quite some time
oh six arjo 6:06 yes that's actually the
same year I created my own personal
YouTube channel but I didn't even treat
it as like a content creation platform
for like five years knows exactly the
same I ignored all that advice about our
growing subscribers and getting regular
content it was just cool they're gonna
host me the video projects I make for
free great lovely
I don't worry about bandwidth I don't
have
about transcoding or anything like that
it just works but I wasn't doing
anything on the platform I was just
using them as a video host right yeah
and it wasn't until many years later
that I'd finally start a series on there
so that's why I should've been doing
okay fine so one of your earliest videos
in fact is probably one of your first
videos to really blow up was to drums
and assemble you basically went to a
cliff and he threw off two drums in a
sentence no joke yeah so yeah III didn't
I've never actually heard the origin of
that so this is a joke or is that an
actual there is no there is an old joke
- drums a cymbal fall of a cliff yeah as
anything like that I was still a student
well so at university anyway um and I
would regularly just have conversations
in the pub with friends and these ideas
would come up and at that point I didn't
know what I wanted to do I was just
throwing ideas at the internet for
anything that we could come up with and
see what worked and this was such a such
a ridiculous idea is like so a cliff
near here I don't know like we didn't
have smartphones it's all right I found
the cliff bought a kid's drum a kids
drum set off eBay hmm went out of the
cliff threw them off take three made the
noise your first take but it wasn't
faked either it was not faked but if you
look back at that video you can see just
how much I was not playing into the
YouTube style there okay was it's got
credits for God's sake because because
that's what I said of pushing just
subscribe you push to a website yeah
like Tom Scott calm yeah because that's
where I was hosting everything because I
mean even now I still miss the old kind
of freer Internet like the idea that you
would have a blog and you would have
something that you controlled on your
website yeah but you were paying for and
that I recognized why that's not
sustainable in the modern era I
recognized that is not but it is not
reasonable to ask loads of people to
learn HTML in order to publish things
onto the Internet um but I do miss that
idea that you are the host of your own
content
and there's a lot of you know there's a
lot of reasoning behind doing that I
know that's roosterteeth is probably the
most famous model these days because
they host everything on their own
website they also have stuff on YouTube
and all the other social media platforms
but like they had their really strong
into like you know don't have your bread
basket yeah only YouTube which is never
fantastic idea I'm I mean for crying out
loud they've they've been going for how
long I remember them doing red vs. blue
yeah I mean he doesn't two - yeah three
yeah
so I mean back then you had to host
through something like that you decide
to run it yourself yeah so you've got
that started up you might as well keep
using it but you know when when you can
host it yourself and have to pay for the
bandwidth versus having YouTube host it
handle everything for you and give you a
cut of the ad revenue yeah it's not a
difficult decision yeah it's it's way
more efficient and easy that way I mean
I'm pretty sure our whole platform is
like pretty much just YouTube well now
with this podcast we got we've got other
audio platforms as well so I genuinely
thought you were going into an a hundred
then I genuinely thought you were
looking to look down the barrel of the
camera I'm just shamelessly segue into
into an ad-free
I feel like I do that enough so no I
wasn't doing that here we're not we're
not big enough for ads just yeah yeah um
so going back to some of the videos that
you've made you also did a video that I
wanted to talk about which was the
McCulloch effect you there's no yes that
you said will ruin your brain I mean
like if you want like the early
clickbait cuz I I don't like that video
really it was one of the it was one of
the first things I didn't the the things
you might not know series that I'm doing
and when I was starting out with that it
was liturgist here's some things I
remember I'll do a bit of research to
make sure they're roughly okay ray I'll
go somewhere I'll film it into my phone
held out like that and ie
would do that video so differently now I
would actually go to someone who is a
neurologist who understands the effects
I would demonstrate it in a different
way I would not film it in Disneyworld
because that's where I happened to be
with friends when the starting so to
preface like what that video is there
everyone's familiar with like oh here's
this like red and
orange or blue image and you stare at it
for like 15 seconds and you look away
and suddenly you're seeing the inverse
of those colors on a wall or wherever
you're looking it's like burned into
your brain but this was a specific image
of like vertical black and red bars or
horizontal black and blue bars that if
you actually stare at it long enough for
like 15 minutes I think you said it's
something like it was stick with your
brain like it'll actually weeks how yeah
like if you do text editing for a living
because it's on on horizontal bars I
think so text is horizontal black bars
if it's a bit fuzzy so you may start to
see the same fringes on that if you work
with video editing it's really bad to
look at that image and like the angle I
went with it was this is like the old
don't stick beans up your nose thing if
you tell a kid yeah stick beans up your
nose then you've just introduced this
wonderful new idea sticking beans up you
knows the thing that is possible in the
world it wasn't until you said that this
could affect you for up to like three
months yet I realized I'm not gonna look
at this and yeah because I hadn't really
been looking at it but I was considering
like just seeing it and see if it would
work but then you said it'll mess with
your brain for three months I I
specifically avoided my eye as much as I
could I need I should be referencing
neurologist I should be referencing the
papers this worked on that they worked
on I should ideally be talking to them
in getting their opinion on this but I
was just starting out at that point
it's it's me just and I still in so I
still do videos like that I missed a lot
of fun but anything that is about
something I am not qualified in I made
sure that I handover or at least
reference the work of right someone who
actually does know what they're talking
about well I feel like that's kind of
become the standard in educational
content these days is to make sure you
fact-checked your stuff there's like
actual educational integrity in what
you're saying hopefully yeah and but
like that was several years ago when you
made that and so you've got ideas now so
it's been a long time and I feel like a
lot of like not just you in particular
but like the whole platform I think has
grown to kind of acknowledge and accept
there's a certain level that like
there's a bar that we're setting as
creators for for accuracy and very
integrity but an algorithm
determine truth and it can't determine
whether something is actually
high-quality but I could absolutely
produce a video that was plausible but
completely false okay
and unless you checked and then you know
manage the comments to make sure no one
called it out and that would be okay we
saw this with I'm gonna mispronounce
this okay bring it on
cuz exact you know those channels sure
let's go yes um they amazing channel
baby oh it's lovely they did a video
recently on what would happen if you
detonated a nuclear bomb in the Marianas
Trench deepest spot in the ocean yeah
and their conclusion is not much you
would kill a few fish uh you would
create a big bubble of the surface mhm
but other than that not much it's not
like it's gonna crack the Marianas
Trench in half or anything like that
because a huge tsunami right but they
are they never actually mentioned it
explicitly but they are calling out a
video from a clickbait channel that
basically said all that a year or so
earlier and which has millions and
millions of views on what is uh I think
what Carl Sagan would call baloney
really it's it's just not it's it's
wrong it's not even plausibly wrong it's
not even you misunderstood what was
going on here it's just wrong straight
up a lie at that point I don't so why is
a very loaded because it like insinuates
like intention perhaps yeah okay um it's
certainly someone who has not done any
fact-checking
and while they're not calling that out
explicitly it's it's for place to search
terms for that but that video was
getting recommended because people kept
clicking on it was incredibly well to do
so they watch to the end and I think
there's certainly a requirement among
the folks who are explicitly doing
educational stuff in the space that I'm
in and that you're in with your big
videos about SpaceX and size of size the
solar system like that yeah we fact
check but that's not a requirement for
getting popular ray
that is a scary thing because it's like
we're all we all understand that we're
kind of just self-regulating here but
because you don't have to some some
person just chasing the algorithm trends
doesn't care about unless that's true
with ancient aliens that's truly the
load of stuff it's on television as well
it's not a unique problem to YouTube hmm
but it is one that is it can very easily
become a problem and it can very easily
serve to folks who won't know that it's
just a bit of a laugh although again
true with ancient aliens yeah I feel
like that's becoming a real issue these
days with misinformation and whatnot is
so easy to share misinformation in it's
so much harder to correct that see how I
come from the UK and we have a lot of
tabloid journalism like that there is
fairly often a correction that you'll
see from something that was on the front
page of one of the tabloids and the
correction is just in tiny print inside
the magazine because that's what they're
required to do no one clicks on
Corrections no one picks up papers with
based on a correction like oh they
corrected something I gotta find out
right I mean those are the whole
reproducibility scandal in psychology I
think last year I'll say reproducibility
yeah of some researchers just trying to
reproduce other papers if they just took
the exact methodology that another
research were done and repeated the
experiment and a lot of the times it
didn't work not to that significance
interesting now how much of that is luck
how much of that is what you what you
call pea hacking picking the significant
results I don't know but there is a lot
of science out there that he's built on
shaky ground as well so it's not unique
to us it's not unique to creators and
all we can ever do is hope that it
becomes okay
but the good stuff rises to the top yeah
so Tom you speak very eloquently and the
dictation is fantastic someone is gonna
patent you because he said dictation and
not diction I mean someone's dictating
that you're right diction so you have a
degree in linguistics yeah
that's that's really fascinating to me I
don't really know what that all entails
so know it specially the study of
everything to do with language apart
from what people make with it so it's
not the study of literature and and
Shakespeare and everything like that
it's a study of everything from how your
vocal tract makes sounds to how your
brain parses sentences so it's
everything to do with language apart
from the results of it now does that go
into like phonetics as well like like
how words are pronounced how certain eye
marks of words are pronounced yeah I did
not study phonetics past the first year
it was one of the basic foundation
modules okay I am really bad at what
they call production so one of the tests
in phonetics is that they will put the
symbol for a particular sound up okay
and in an exam like this you have to
make that sound and that includes sounds
that are not from the language you speak
so there is a difference in some
languages between
I'm gonna do that again I'm gonna
apologize the tech crew hits and they're
leaning closer to the mic it's the
difference between and and if you hear
that okay that aspiration that was on
the second one yeah so it's just a noise
just a pea with no air coming out and
where you're really kind of exploding
air that's the extreme difference and
there are lots of languages where that
and there lots of language where those
are distinct sounds ah okay and I know
in Vietnamese Vietnamese is very much so
it'll be the same word same spelling but
with all the s symbols on tonal it's a
tunnel yeah yeah and there's a word uh
and I I will always fail to pronounce it
correctly but there's three different
ways to pronounce it's like mm-hmm
good luck I know I'm certain that is
wrong but it basically translates to I
think like new salt and mosquito Wow
yeah and there are equivalent things in
English as well so speakers of East
Asian languages often have trouble with
ours and owls and distinguishing them
okay in English and that's because those
are effectively the same sound or
they're not distinguished and saying in
the same way that putin per aren't over
here are me so actually right so this is
an entire video i did years ago so i did
a series on linguistics it was the thing
I was actually qualified to talk about
um how do you make a sound for if I BR
in around like what does your what your
mouth actually do when you say it was
out like so round so the bits inside the
two normal ways of doing that are either
you take your tongue and you put it near
the top
I like the alveolar Ridge which the bit
just behind your teeth better okay uh
and it's like an L so it's around and
around or you can do it like a V like a
loose V a round of round so this is
where we zoom in clogs on your face as
you try and work out how you make that
are sound around around is it top teeth
bottom lip or is it tongue and the ridge
behind your teeth when I say when I'm
pronouncing that are my tongue is
actually kind of back in my mouth kind
of like sitting low and back a
okay what are you talk is it constable V
is it close to an L it's closer to a V
right so that is technically a speech
defect what are you calling me defective
it's the same one I've got and this is
the same one that maybe I mean no one's
done as far as I know the research on
this I haven't checked in the last few
years so maybe this has been updated but
that is now somewhere between a quarter
and a half maybe even more of
english-speakers RH and if you go to
generations back that was a defect that
is Elmer Fudd Elmer Fudd sang is gonna
catch that wob it
that's that defect really it's top teeth
bottom lip it's that he's not saying
grab it he's saying rabbit he's just
missing there okay and that speech
defect it has just become standard now
so we're all kind of like Elmer Fudd now
so this is one of the things you get
taught the very thing the very first
thing that gets drilled into you in
linguistics is that actually I shouldn't
use the term defect I'm using it's an
easier thing to say here it is
non-standard speech you never make value
judgments on something like that you can
say it's standard or non-standard okay
but you never say that one way of
speaking is correct and the other is
wrong so right defect is is perhaps a
the wrong term to use but it is
certainly a non-standard way of speaking
except suddenly out of nowhere in the
last half-century it's normal and
everyone's okay with it and as far as I
know no one has worked out why does this
happen because not something you'd
notice that's crazy
I never knew that thank you for taking
this that is a video like I've just
badly repeated an old video I did like
six years ago but sure yeah oh I'll take
that so yeah I did linguistics I also
educational studies which was a research
degree research master's degree and then
I decided that I wanted to get the heck
out of university uh after many years
forty many years and ended up doing this
there were a lot of other things in
between mind so when you first started
making videos was that like something
you wanted to do I know you said that
you were kind of just spitballing and
throwing a lot of stuff at the internet
seeing what you wanted to do but video
production specifically was that
something that you're like you know what
I know how to use a camera I'm
I'm good at talking in front of a kid I
learned those things okay as I needed to
have I mean I think it's something I
have always been attracted towards I
think if you if you have all those
various things that could have pulled me
towards them and could have take me on
that path yeah this was certainly gonna
be one of the attractors that I could
have been orbiting around but I learned
it because I wanted to there was a
project that needed video I guess it
gotta learn how to edit now and that was
when I was like 16 17 it never actually
made it out to the Internet but it's
like okay that's that's something of a
learn now I you know okay I'm five years
later oh I guess I need to do another
thing with video all right let's do that
oh we had this idea what doesn't work as
a video all right dig those skills out
but at the same time I was checking out
images and text and anything in any
format because the alternative was not
doing yeah fair enough
well yeah I mean you've made it this far
you're one of the top educators on
YouTube right now man that's a strange
thing to say yes it's been it has been
literally 15 years of throwing stuff at
the internet before something before
before getting there like it's it's a
slow path to get there but there are
exceptions but basically everyone who
looks like an overnight success has been
doing this for so long but there's
usually a lot of hard work involved in
luck yeah so to transition a little bit
um no you're absolutely right though um
there is a lot of hot it's the
difference between rolling one dice and
hoping that it comes up a six versus
rolling a hundred dice on one of them
and knowing that something's gonna work
the more ideas you check out more
different things that the better the
chance you have of rolla sakes I always
tell people who are trying to get into
like making videos I just tell them just
just do it yeah you know like the throw
the Nike slogan at their face like just
do it make stuff don't worry about how
good it is just make it and move on to
the next one just like all right now
you've done that stop front fretting
over this video move on to the next
video and just keep doing it over and
over and over again I remember someone I
cannot remember who sign your first
hundred video is gonna suck just just
deal with it they're gonna suck you're
gonna hate them afterwards but you need
to put the time in with with rare very
rare exceptions you need to put the time
in and you see this way
with the folks who did have that one hit
very early on
um the the kid from David after dentist
if you remember that yeah yes he has a
gaming channel now she does yeah the go
to the dead the kid he's got a couple
hundred subscribers because they weren't
interested in him they were interesting
that one video right yeah and up into
everything else
yeah cuz that was a huge viral hit and
you see that a lot these days with
people who will have some sort of like
viral thing happen maybe it's not a
video but some sort of thing happens and
they just try to capitalize on that as
long as they can which I can't judge I'm
like hey you're given an opportunity and
you're just like trying to I'm never I'm
never gonna say anything bad about
someone's hustle like great yeah go for
it but you gotta know that they're
interested in the thing you were in and
not you
yeah I'm trying to manage the boundaries
between that is often a difficult thing
to do speaking of difficult things you
have done some difficult things you've
done some really cool things that I
realized cool and difficult anyway
you've you flown in fighter jets you've
gone in the Vomit Comet you've done
you've been in a centrifuge all these
things have in common that is more or
less in the past year like past year
past 15 months as crazy I hate roller
coasters to this day I still hate roller
coasters so which came first the the
flight the centrifuge or the 0 to 0 G 0
G came first
yes so just as as background there was a
video of me many many years ago on what
is called a robo coaster oh there were a
couple of these in the world I think
there's one or two in the US I know
Legoland in Europe has one in the
Netherlands and there is one on on a
seaside pier in England something I
don't know if it's still there it is a
industrial grade robot arm okay okay two
seats on the end of it they haven't
bothered to theme it they haven't
bothered to make it put a superhero's
name or anything on that it's called a
robo coaster it is a robot arm with two
seats on it would you like a go give us
some money here you go
yes yeah I'm just like so Denning what
setting would you like it by setting one
for kids
it'll just up and you sort of steadily
take them on a nice setting five it will
swing you around what you've been
grabbed
by the Hulk that's awesome I know I went
on that because it was a stupid idea
that was being thrown out I attached a
couple GoPros to it um and this was way
before I was doing like educational
stuff and I discovered that was okay it
was unpleasant because it was high
g-forces mm-hmm but for some reason I
was okay with it but like put me on
Pirates of the Caribbean at Disney which
has like a tiny log flume drop it's not
it's hardly anything now I don't like it
and it's it's specifically that that
combination of psychologically knowing
you're suddenly dropping and the actual
feeling that you get when you when you
go over a humpback bridge or something
like oh yeah we get us that specific
swift transition to a drop yeah I really
really hate that feeling so that that
transition yeah yeah and I hate the
nerves that lead up to it which of
course make it worse because
everything's pulling in like
psychological that's really really
difficult for me but like the European
Space Agency he helped me out of nowhere
oh it was no no where I I did something
with one of their facilities six months
early but I haven't gone through Easter
I'd gone through the local university
okay
and apparently folks DISA went oh he
should have gone to us and why was we
melt it that we never emailed him uh
apparently I was on the list of folks to
contact and had been for a while and
they just not got around to it
so I got this email that said like
should be on it was called a drop tower
it's not for human use but it's
basically a giant slingshot in a hundred
meter or so tall tower and the sample
gets about nine seconds of freefall
because you get four and a half going up
or and a half coming back down Wow
yeah that it smashes into a pit of
polystyrene beads mm-hmm and it's it
stops in about 22 G's so definite not
for human use yeah but if you want nine
seconds of freefall and zero-g
relatively cheaply you put the sample in
there you evacuate all the air from the
tower right it works I went there film
that and then we've got loads of
facilities like that and you know we
might be able to put you on a zero g
flight not gonna turn you down i it's
entirely possible i'm i might you know i
might not be able to do it but
and then next meeting this like so we've
put you in for this flight on this date
huh okay it's this is real it's moving
forward and it was genuinely possible
for me that I was going to completely
freak out I have not been on anything
like that in years I'm not blonde roller
coaster in years because I know I don't
like them I never liked them since I was
a kid I hate that feeling of of dropping
and it was a very real possibility as I
as I go into that it was a very real
possibility that I would freak out my
worst case scenario was I was literally
panic and lose bladder control like
that's and that was within the realm of
possibility and then I'm sat there and
we do the pull-up in 22.2 jeez okay it's
fine oh it's fine it's fine I'm Wiest it
just feels normal
really it does not feel like you're
going over a hump Oh Bridget it's all
right the fact that effect you're going
over the biggest humpback bridge in the
world yeah it doesn't feel like I think
that's because it's a slow transition I
think that's because you go kind of 2.2
Gees 1.5 no point nine not point four
zero and no point does the floor drop
out from under you it just steadily easy
so if they were to suddenly dive way
quicker than they normally do you
probably get a little bit more of that
drop honestly I felt worse when we had a
bit of turbulence after takeoff and the
plane was going down but I did at any
point during the freefall that's crazy
so honestly if and I realize that this
is an incredibly privileged position to
be in if you can afford the the four or
five thousand because I got to e so it
was it was a research flight it was just
a gift
uh-huh if you can afford four or five
grand or however much it costs to do
that in Vegas yeah in Orlando on one of
the big zero-g flight do it it is unlike
anything else it is it is like a dream
of flying I want to do it again but
cannot justify spending that kind of
money on it so a part that I think a lot
of people don't ever really realize when
it comes to doing a flight like that is
you're actually undergoing a lot of
gravity on your way up yeah and on the
pull out because because at the end of
it Oh accelerating towards the ground so
does
don't you mix in the ground they have
people to point to on the way out so
that means your year over twice as heavy
when when you're going through those
segments and I always I've never really
experienced like a sustained two G like
downwards force before and so I've
always wanted to feel like how heavy are
my arms oh yeah you mentioned I remember
you mentioning something that was crazy
which was you get instant nausea when
you move your head yeah under those
situations move your head all the stuff
in your inner ear that works out how
that is when you move your head
it moves differently out of parently in
zero-g that's okay we can deal with that
everything's floating to point to you
brain just cannot deal with it
nope you're instantly nauseous I'm
reading this book series called the
expanse yeah and in that it's it's a
sci-fi series where they're you know
flying across the solar system and
they've got these thrusters that are
able to just constantly put out a lot of
thrust and usually they just sit at like
1 G so they can have like normal gravity
and their Tower of a spaceship but
anytime they're having to do high G
maneuvers or anything like that they
have to sit in these special chairs ok
makes sense but they get injected with
tons of drugs to counteract all the
nausea and I just remember thinking how
do you get I got scopolamine which is
the good anti-nausea drug in because it
was European Space Agency flight it was
proper injectable prescribed by a doctor
I'm for me and I don't if this was true
for other people it removed the ability
to vomit but not the desire
oh that sounds it also removed all
moisture from a cottonmouth yeah like
the first drop there's this ah nose I
make I think ruin my throat for days
afterwards - but I'm trying to do a bit
to camera this is this is what happens
in all this stuff that I've done in the
last year um a lot of folks have done
things like this and I like I like doing
one take videos I like trying to make
sure I can get a script out under
strange circumstances at the most recent
one was wing-walking which is where you
are you know there's old biplanes with -
yes
they walk out into the wing Hall dance
like a yeah I mean the commercial
version these days that you are strapped
into the top of the wing it's basically
it's basically standing seat
yeah on top of the top wing um yeah
right 120 mile an hour wind placed a
camera but I try and do this because
it's a skill I seem to have been able to
do and it's mostly showing off but it's
a lot of fun to be able to be not just
talking on the ground about this is what
I did but no I'm in the moment right now
and I'm going to try and get this and
describe it to you while I'm doing it
you did that when you're flying in that
fighter jet
yeah the hawk t1 t1 which this is the
Royal Air Force red arrows so so yeah
the Royal Air Force have the red arrows
display team so that's like the Blue
Angels or the Thunderbirds for the for
the US I think it's one from Canada
France or a couple of other countries
that have them mm-hmm but their job is
make us look good
their job they are not just the best of
the best in terms of pilots but they're
also the pilots that get on with each
other for the red arrows you have to be
selected by the existing red arrows
because you are can have to have a
reporter you're flying dashes from each
other you're depending on each other for
your life and that was that was a big
deal um and I think for a lot of folks
watching that outside the UK the red
arrows are a symbol of Britain they are
really something that there is an icon
of of the country hmm this is not
something that they offer this was out
this was but this wasn't even a dream
come true because unless you are that
sort of kid who dreams of becoming a
fighter pilot and yeah then then maybe
but you can't do that as a civilian yeah
you can't pay for that because you can't
a good option you can't pay the military
to do things because that is a coop just
being able to to be up there is
something like I am I'm worried that
maybe the peak of my life as I say on a
scale of 1 to 10 how much fun was that
is that like is that a little an 11
after takeoff it's a 10 but again don't
like roller coasters don't
g-forces and I'm going to fight it yet
yeah this is the same problem so I've
done some I've done a glider before I've
done a couple things like that like okay
I don't know how it's gonna be and we
take off in formation we take off wrong
yeah I know right
I and it felt like a regular airplane
takeoff we nearly you know just it was a
bit faster maybe but it's okay oh we're
off the ground now
oh but we're a tiny plane why are we not
being battered around by the oh we're in
a jet yeah just get out of the way yeah
we did yeah again it didn't feel like
dropping at any point so I was fine we
pulled some high G maneuvers mhm
um we pulled a loop which was maybe
three foot also I'm wearing G trousers
with the ones that like squeeze your
legs they'll literally connect to a
compressed air port in the plane and
when the plane detects it it's going
into 2g or something like that
you and you you basically wrapped in a
lower-body torniquet yeah so all the
blood stays up here and now do you have
to do your breathing procedures on top
of that they did they did not give it
week they did not do any maneuvers that
would put civilians above their comfort
zone okay what are the weather the best
possible the nicknames for the pilots
you know how Top Gun has maverick yeah
okay goose which is the cosines right
yeah fighter pilot call signs are
nicknames meant to be badass
so ba guy was one of the ones who is
flying with us okay but no bo g ba GOG
it turns out that the British pilot cool
songs and nicknames are not quite as
cool as Top Gun it's great but the folks
with flight like one of them except I
talk to the pilots beforehand one says
yes I'll pulled about 9g in a maneuver
the other day like you can still see the
burst blood vessels okay right that's
like we're not putting you through
anything like that but we had to have a
safety brief yeah but we had a half our
safety briefing beforehand that's all
yeah I'm saying we because I wasn't the
only one though there are a couple of us
okay um half of it was to do with you
laughs it was don't touch anything
except for these specific things we
needed to touch to make sure your chair
is in don't touch anything
unless you have to in which case here is
how to use your ejector seat so this is
actually a slightly darker to talk about
now because a couple of weeks after that
video went out they had a crash they
lost one of the engineers which when one
of the pilots so know what so it's a two
seater plane and when they are
transiting between locations they take
there is one engineer per plane and they
will travel in the plane with them yeah
and there was an incident on takeoff I
haven't seen the accident reported on if
it's come out yet but they lost a plane
and one of the engineers didn't eject in
time it's yeah this this is not
something that civilians get to do often
for a reason mm-hmm and this was a
serious half hour briefing that I don't
a--first with the exact words but the
you know the phrasing was essentially if
you see your pilot leave the plane you
need to follow um if your pilot is
incapacitated you should eject you
cannot fly this plane and by the time
you realize you can't fly this plane it
will be too late to eject by the way
when you eject you will be unconscious
and you will wake up in pain either
under a parachute or on the ground what
kind of g-forces do you undergo when you
do eject a lot I don't know what the
numbers are but it basic i wasn't
peeking just like above the threshold of
just passing out yeah um the the rumor
is I don't have this true the pilots are
only allowed to eject a couple of times
in their career because it can break
your spine if you are to like no one if
I was a few inches taller I would not
have been allowed to fly because their
words not all of you will leave the
plane um if you're to these fighter jets
are designed for a specific body type
yeah
if you are too tall in the leg uh then
because you the first thing we'll do is
is pull your knees in and pull your legs
behind the seat so if you if you are too
tall it will do that and then it will
eject and your knees will get removed on
the way out yeah if you are too light
very light
you can't eject because they can't
calibrate the rockets that fire you that
LA and the g-force will break your spine
and exit
business any sense this is serious
military equipment and it was a really
serious thing to go through and and like
we get up there I'm a pilot
you know once we're out of formation
we're doing they've literally they've
put five minutes in here to show off I
said we're gonna do a loop we're gonna
surf through the top of the clouds this
is great but at the same time this is
serious and if something goes wrong this
is not built to civilian standards is
built to military standards and we need
to be ready for now something that you
mentioned earlier is like you you like
to do these one takes and when you're up
on in that jet you did that you are
actually given a whole monologue about I
don't know if you had a script prepared
ahead of time a lot of cuts in that
video so there is only one camera with
me in the plane yes and it was the GoPro
fusion right yes cuz you've done a lot
of stuff with 360 as well so you know
some of the difficulties and somebody
remember seeing the shadow of the fusion
I was like I know what that camera is so
yeah you were using that brilliantly for
getting shots of you but also getting
any other shots like forward to the side
so all the same time I I'm glad I went
with that it was the right decision I
was really worried about it we could not
I say we because it was me the film crew
everyone around it we were not allowed
to attach anything to the interior of
the plane everything had to be handheld
and so I can tell if something's
starting to break or if my hands doesn't
get tired and I can put the thing away
and that's fine if the GoPro mount is
starting to get tired from 3G 4G
maneuvers yeah and it comes off at a bad
time and hits a button then we're dead
and that's not exaggeration
yeah that's that's like it gets stuck
somehow and accidentally triggers the
ejector seat that's a possibility
so nothing mounts to the plate it has
been done before by the BBC many years
ago but of having they had a
custom-built mount that was rated for
one flight by a whole team oh gosh
so like a huge factor of safety involved
here this is not coming off and even
with that so I made it so I have a
fusion on a stick I'm trying to hold it
steady in three and four
maneuvers and still do the bit to camera
and still get all the other shots and it
worked because
we didn't have a second take on this we
didn't have a second attempt yeah um
yeah it looked really good too like it
wasn't until the end of the video I
don't realize there's a 360 camera
because it just looks like a GoPro yeah
like it you know good color quality good
resolution
I was surprised yes I was high so yeah I
have got to do a lot of really cool
stuff this year I'm partly that's
because you know privileged position
spend a long time working to be here
partly it's contacts and partly it's
because I've been doing this stuff for
long enough that I seem to be trusted to
do this now yeah and I know it won't
last forever you know if we if we're
talking about creative process we're
talking about long term stuff here I
know this can't last forever there isn't
but it is a very rare thing in the world
to be a part of a band or part of a
television show part of anything that
can survive past that like the first few
years if you're lucky a rest so how you
move that on to other stuff is a big
deal if this is the peak for me then
it's a really really good peak I just
need to prepare for whatever's next so
when you're in that centrifuge which is
the thing that simulates just haiji
manoeuvres yeah just a lot of gravity
you wha did you ever get any amount of
motion sickness from that because that's
that's what I would be afraid of because
you're in this thing yeah it simulates a
lot of high gravity but you're also
spinning in a circle I'm I would be
afraid that I'd get carsick no I don't
think it was long enough to do that my
eye line was kind of stuck on the camera
again in that one but I passed out you
know what were the highest Jeezy took in
that embarassingly 3.6 which is not much
the RAF engineer who went in to
demonstrate it for their shuttle
pulled I think he meant five and he's
wearing G trousers flat and doing this
training maneuvers everything and he
doesn't he doesn't look like he's having
a good time um but he survived it it's
fine that's what he does I passed out at
3.6 with breathing manoeuvres which
essentially means I failed astronaut
selection which is okay like I always
knew somewhere deep down I'm not gonna
be an astronaut right like growing up as
a kid I was not particularly athletic I
didn't want to go in for the fighter
part or anything like that my eyes are
I'm so short-sighted that I can barely
see my hand in front of my face from it
won't come tactless um I knew I that in
theory I'd always fail astronaut
selection but then I actually failed
astronaut selection I knew that's a
really brutal thing to find out it
really is astronauts who go through that
selection do is there a certain amount
of G's that they have to stay away it's
more than three points and like no I I
don't I think it's somewhere around four
or five okay that was like the the
highest amount that they would put a
civilian through yeah I don't know four
point five is the maximum they'll put a
civilian but you pass out three points
yes it so the moment you pass out of a
ticket geez I hit B the e stop the
moment now something that I also know
about g-forces is that so that was
axially downwards yeah that was wave
yeah eyes down is that what it's called
yeah interesting versus like high
acceleration down a track gingy so
there's eyes down and eyes in yeah okay
I didn't know that now eyes in you can
handle way higher g-forces than eyes
down the Sun five the one we were
talking about earlier the astronauts are
lying down at the top of it so I think
that is eyes in g-force yes it should be
a deliberate choice yeah right and
that's because the blood is it's moving
in you but it's still everywhere eyes
down g-force is difficult because the
blood pools in your feet and goes away
from your brain right
do you know cuz that there's that guy
who did that track where he accelerated
really fast yeah he's gone like what
like 25 G's it's the things that
accelerating people is the difficult
part like if you want high G's on on
acceleration you need loads of rockets
need loads everything high G's on
deceleration you just see the wall yeah
just jump off a bridge yeah like it okay
you'll get really love Jesus so you'll
get really high G's when you hit the
ground yeah um what they actually was a
scoop in the front of rocket sled so
just kind of went through a water trough
and slowed them down a little more
gradually but that's still like
20-something G's briefly and yeah human
body can take that briefly yeah that's
so crazy so when you're when you're in
the centrifuge did you try like lifting
your hands that oh yeah you just were
holding weights on yeah
it's I mean at the same point my brain
is starting to lose blood so I'm so good
yeah it's fine
my fishings growing out a bit though is
this normal is this there's a medical
officer in the middle of a centrifuge
that is also spinning yeah so it this is
about to get decommissioned this is the
last of the the old RAF training
centrifuges that were built I want to
say 1950s forties or fifties I think and
it's built like you sitting in what
looks like a cockpit from them it's all
mechanical there are computers managing
it now and CCTV cameras in it but it's
it's essentially just been retrofitted
in it's a big mechanical spinny
slingshot the new one that they are
about to open is a full motion simulator
so it's got three axis motion simulator
on a centrifuge arm that's cool I mean
they go from 0 to 9 G's in a second
which is what which is what a 5 second
dip so it's not just training pilots to
withstand this now it's literally we're
gonna put you in a cockpit of a fighter
jet and it and you're gonna pull back on
that stick and you are you're going 4
G's now dang that's a much more accurate
test something that you mentioned and
this is I think this falls in line with
like basically calculus right and that's
the derivatives of you go from distance
to speed to acceleration and you know
the speed is the change of distance and
acceleration is the change of speed and
Joe and then Jurgis is the change of
acceleration you could be accelerating
at a constant rate of acceleration even
though your speed is rapidly increasing
yeah but if you were to increase the
rate of acceleration change now that is
increasing the amount of jerk so this is
like you talking about the expanse it's
the difference between 1g kicking in
because of thrust goes hmm I know
everyone is who is floating there
something goes all right we're on the
ground now yeah versus what I did in the
zero-g thing I've going all right not
point to 0.51 and I'm back on the ground
and it's it's a tricky thing to get your
head round but it does make a big
difference to how you feel in because I
remember when I first discovered that
when I was taking calculus like that was
that was the coolest thing to me is that
this is all just it's all it's all just
math and but I didn't realize
that these had names beyond jerk and
what were those names it's is it some
snap crackle and pop yeah which is a
reference that is not going to lend for
Americans really I did those would be
anything to you we have rice crispies
okay they do land oh I thought that was
just a British thing is it okay I don't
know I've because I grew up with Rice
Krispies a very good cereal and you pour
like milk in it and it starts like that
was just a British thing okay manna my
American references are rare and not as
up-to-date but I so yeah I remember you
mentioning that you know crackle and pop
or just such a high level derivatives
that there's almost no use for them yeah
but it's cool the trouble is of the the
units you're also talking about there
are so small as to be meaningless when
you've got meters per second per second
per second per second
it's not helpful think it's like knowing
the hundreds digit of pi is great it's
not gonna help you actually do stuff
right okay whereas jerk you also
mentioned jerk isn't really heavily
researched yeah I think I was more me
hunting for conclusion to a video but
sure cuz yeah because you can't really
research jerk without also researching
acceleration yeah they they tie in very
closely but hey they've now got the the
RAF centrifuge that will do that will
have that high jerk capacity it will
take you from yeah 0 to 9 G that quickly
so maybe they can nail you have another
video series online now that deals with
super intelligence AI futurology stuff
like that but your take on it is very
bleak very depressing in a weird way so
it's not like the Terminator style of AI
takes over everything but it's also not
the glorious we are now basically living
in heaven on earth sort of way you're
going down a depressingly realistic
seeming outcome with your idea of the
future of artificial intelligence so my
problem is that I cannot write
characters and I cannot write dialogue
I am which let's be honest I'm not there
are plenty of all published authors who
can't do that but um I don't I'm sure
that given you know ten years of
learning it I could back and maybe do it
but I have never been able I would never
put the hours in to be able to write
convincing characters okay so the sci-fi
stuff their hand and I used to do sci-fi
back before I was doing the kind of
factual stuff that I'm doing now like
there's a long history of me doing
one-off videos about sci-fi stuff would
you often kind of singularity AI stuff
back then um but a lot of folks
particularly because it gets compared to
black mirror because obviously
everything that is vaguely it used to be
compared to the twilight zone now it's
compared to black mirror uh-huh
I don't know Jordan peels now reboot in
the try though Twilight Zone so maybe
that's all yeah maybe it'll go back to
that but they're all dramas they are all
something from this kind of third-person
perspective where you have actors and
you have direction and you clearly have
a narrative whereas because that's not
my skill I just kind of cut all that out
and just boil it down for minimum idea
and then put it so that it is everything
is diegetic everything that you've seen
in the video is something that you would
see for that product pitch or that yeah
don't worry or that TED talk or whatever
yeah and for me that's it's both an
easier way to write and a quicker way to
write I don't need to worry that my
characters are convincing or have our
emotional arcs or anything like that I
can just say here's an idea and that's
kind of why I read science fiction as
well so absolutely but that's what I
like about those videos that you've made
is that it presents these interesting
ideas without any side like or
distractions so for instance the welcome
to life video you made several years ago
that yeah that was before things you
might not know I think that was that was
a long long time ago now yeah and that
video just kind of deals with okay
you're able to upload your brain to the
servers now what does that actually mean
people because we kind of see that now
it's like oh you can get your Kindle for
cheaper if you allow ads on your Kindle
and it's like that's sort of like mine
space I mean oh lying that to you all
under brains all I'm doing is in the
description is all is taking bits that
other science fiction authors have
written before
and putting them in a new context with a
slightly new idea on them and that's
what most science fiction authors do hmm
but the idea of the idea of uploading
your brain is an old science fiction
idea yeah the idea of a
corporate-sponsored afterlife is so that
what the book is called everyone in
silica or silicon by it's Jim Munroe
okay you're gonna have to put a
correction on screen Eve I haven't got
that right he released it for free under
Creative Commons maybe ten years ago now
it's a very different take on it he can
write characters he can write dialogue
but the idea was that yeah there is this
digital world you can upload yourself
into but of course as a monthly fee for
it and of course if you can't pay that
that monthly fee well it can be
advertiser supported um the idea of the
thing that really messed with me was
that oh and you can get the cheaper tier
where you are allowing them to kind of
alter your your thinking yeah and so
that's these memories but that was
inspired by a Rudy Rucker book called
post singular which it's really trippy
because a lot of stuff that Rudy Rucker
writes is really trippy and there's just
one section near the end which just
mentioned in passing that the the AI
controlling the world was just
simulating people's consciousness at
lower resolution just taking away
consciousness and creativity because
they were just difficult to handle and
for most people who didn't make much
difference and that's that was that kind
of gut punch from that that got
translated into way of course us that's
a monthly subscription of course that's
DLC of some of course that's something
you have to pay for but you can like
actually conform their way of thinking
to align with brands yeah that you know
like them well them that would be bruns
that would do that yeah and that's the
thing because it's like it feels so like
realistic in like well that's how it
kind of works now so why wouldn't it
work if you extrapolate into the future
I'm like this none of this is original
all of this will have been thought of by
someone before and I say this whenever
anyone asks about like oh yeah why'd you
get the idea from like every other
science fiction author out that's a
little I saw something similar and I saw
something similar over
I saw something similar there and then
months later my brain went what if we
put that with that yeah oh of course
yeah of course they change people's
preferences to make to reflect
advertisers yeah I'm I'm certain that
other people will have come up with that
independently on the same thing um it's
just to create the context it's just a
case of grabbing the ideas you know from
wherever and then making it so they
yours
and I really fine line between
plagiarism and inspiration and the trick
is to always have so I I do a panel show
what did a panel show we just ended it
with friends ray called citation needed
which is in the style of every other
panel show and podcast that has been
done over the last or before Britain for
panel shows us decades and I will
occasionally get emails from people
saying can we can we do this can we take
this and do our own version like asking
your permission to kind of copy or show
format and my answer is always the same
it's like there's there's a whole lot of
stuff in there that I cannot copyright
but in the same way that two people sat
in front of microphones having a
conversation yeah you've got no claim of
that what so I have solutely know if
this is corridors take on it and in the
same way the context yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't want you to take the exact
sound effects were using in the exact
words were using but I've got no
copyright open so watch some more shows
take some more ideas find the thing that
no one else has done yet that suits your
audience and the then run with that
because one television come calling or
when YouTube originals come calling
Alliance anyone with a budget comes
calling you don't want to have to say
well actually I took the idea from these
people yeah you want to be able to say
no yeah this is my idea this is what I
did for sure so you also just recently
came out with a video kind of expanding
on that idea but in a very different way
so we've all I mean at least I've done a
lot of reading in research on like the
singularity which is the the inflection
point at which our hardware technology
has gotten good enough to support the
software for a super-intelligent
general AI and it starts as a bit of an
evolution where it's like it finally
gets I guess self-consciousness as smart
as a human and then after a certain
mount of time it's 10 times smarter and
then in a much shorter amount of time
that wasn't times smarter and then
history becomes unpredictable yeah
and not in the sense of like literally
not predictable you cannot predict what
happens beyond that so this this was
your take on the what-if like what would
happen and it was like very interesting
you said earlier it's it's banal futures
it's like a utopia is fun to imagine but
terrible for drama
what a story setting a utopia uh is wish
fulfillment and has no drama isn't that
great to watch it's there's a yes I
guess I book is the right term now it's
a collection of short chapters that were
posted individually that has now become
a book called raah by Hughes ok freely
available online he's just decided to
change the ending of it because he's
thought of a better one and there is one
section in there that just describes a
literal utopia and it's a lovely thing
to read it's genuinely a good idea it's
the first time I've looked a
science-fiction world and thought sounds
nice but then of course it has to break
and it has to come to an end because
people living in a world where
everything's right for them is not a
good thing for drama
so utopia is a crap to write dystopias
are also not as interesting to write
feel like they're a little played out
yeah because if you if you have
something that where everything is
terrible for me at least it's it's not
fun you have to have characters fight
against this saying something I'll do
this this is a bad idea and we shouldn't
do it like thing bad has been done so
many times by so many people in so many
different ways that it feels like
everything has been said everything's
been done but there are a lot of kind of
meddling banal futures we're sure we've
got a digital afterlife but it's it's
pay-per-view and it's DLC so short for
the new one you know we've got we've got
an artificial superintelligence but the
goals were set wrong and now
unfortunately all it's doing is
copyright protection so yeah and if you
haven't seen the video I highly
recommend you go check it out it's
really interesting but the premise of it
is that basically they create the super
intelligence accidentally because
they're just trying to create an AI
that helps regulate copyright on a video
platform kind of like how which is a
stupid idea but there have been a lot of
stupid ideas over the history of
technology like the idea that some
engineer was going to go can we throw AI
at this problem and then use the wrong
AI kick that happens by a miracle to
work yeah look at us it's implausible I
don't think it's impossible I I mean
don't you put it forward in such a way
that makes it seem like it's inevitable
I am actually fairly skeptical about
singularities and everything like that I
think it's far more likely that
technologies is gonna and certainly kind
of computer chips everything like that
is gonna follow the sigmoid curve I
think that's where it's it's going up
really really strongly and then levels
out okay like we are now further away
from the moon landing than the moon
landing was from the Wright brothers yes
so oh I probably got it from your
Twitter yeah but we start on that in you
know a century ago and within 50 60
years we had men on the moon but we
haven't gone anywhere since then we've
actually regrets supersonic commercial
flight is not a thing and it was never
really all that profitable we reached
the peak of where we can go with that
reasonably until there's another step
change and we see that with a lot of
stuff we've seen that with trains we've
seen that with basically every type of
transport yeah and I do think that that
might be happening to computers as well
like we see a step change we went from
no one owns a mobile phone which and
then to the steady launch of I guess
rich business people to have mobile
phones now
- okay everyone's got a mobile phone now
and it's connect to the internet and
okay that's that's a big change
mm-hmm but Twitter's more than 10 years
old now I think Twitter's 11 or 12 years
old huh
we haven't seen exponential growth from
there and I do have this sneaking
suspicion based on nothing more than a
gut feeling that AI is gonna go the same
way that we have this slow slow slow
take off as people try and build you
know very basic things we have the eliza
chat bots everything like that and we
suddenly have a step change of oh okay
we can try and brute force it with
machine learning we've got new systems
that let us
do that we've got adversarial machine
learning this is great we've got loads
of stuff we've got all this gonna be
great this gonna and now it's petered
out and we've got this new technology
that will change our lives but flight
didn't become a singularity we didn't
end up with rockets to the moon
departing from LAX twice a day
phones haven't become like we've not got
Google glass we've not got them embedded
in our heads yet I don't think that's
gonna come for a long long time and my
honest suspicion wait were you asked me
were you to ask me to place money on it
would be that we're not gonna get a
singularity like that which is gonna be
vaguely disappointing for all the tech
no no it's out there ha but do I think
it's vaguely possible at some point
where we should start thinking it's
possible then yeah the episode 3 which
is gonna come out about when this
podcast is released I don't if it's
gonna be day before day yeah um
episode 3 is about mind uploading and
he's really really dark I don't think
this is a possible future I think it's
so far off the branch the possibility
that so many things would have to go
wrong to get there uh and all it is it's
it's stuff that Greg Egan has written
about more about mind uploading and the
rights of copies as as he calls them in
permutation city and whether they count
as human and this is just it's the
Chinese room problem from from many many
years ago but it's filtered through the
lens of YouTube and it's filtered
through the lens of the tropes we have
no but do I think that it's worth
thinking about and preparing for on the
long list of that like things we should
actually care about climate change
halves things we should actually care
about civil rights there they're way
I've put the top of the list there um
but on unlisted you know our list of
things to think about yeah we should
probably just have something in our head
so that the folks who are dealing with a
I are actually consulting ethicists are
actually thinking are we playing with
fire here yeah but probably not well
it's cuz what scares me about that is
that they could just accidentally create
an apocalypse situation that was exactly
what the point of your copyright video
but yeah basically this I this a I just
took the idea of eliminating copyrighted
material from the internet to such a
huge degree that
I started creating trillions of nanobots
to invade everyone's bodies to start
erasing or altering their memories and
then suppressing their desire to find
out what their what they don't really
remember anymore and also suppress their
desire to research into AI more so then
you end up with this one AI kind of
controlling the entire planet forever
after that and that just kind of all
started as a fluke it reminds me of this
other sort of mind game with AI which
was you they tried to create this
program to just print as or to make as
many sheets of paper as possible paper
clips it's because then that ends up
getting out of control and then it's
just it's one prime directive in its
entire AI life is to make as many papers
as possible to the extinction of
humanity in the process yeah because
you've you've given something that his
MA that is smarter than a human a gold
that is accidentally incompatible with
humans in the power to do it yeah and
there's been so much writing about this
over the years you would hope that
anyone working with how I has read it
I mean this goes back to the you know
the stories of genies and bottles you
know be careful what you wish for
because the genie may not take into a
consideration all the things that have
reasonable human would do and I don't
know how you fix that I'm not qualified
as now i f assist or anything like that
you know I've written some science
fiction you would hope that the folks
who are doing this and I know damn well
that google deepmind are based in London
yeah they've got an ethics team they've
got a lot of folks working for you but
they're also under a lot of
non-disclosure agreements and we don't
talk about what they're working on I
think like if you asked me to place a
bet all I'm going to say is it's
probably not gonna happen so how do you
feel about like say the fear mongering
or I don't even know if that sounds a
little too intense but like say Elon
Musk is basically cautioning everyone to
slow down the AI research like let's you
know bring in some ethics into all of
this and figure out the right way to do
this and then you have other people
saying no you're not gonna slow me down
I'm gonna research this until we get
something great because at the end of
the day it is a competition between
everyone to to do whatever they're doing
and they're using AI as a tool and
they're gonna keep trying to push the
envelope with AI to help them in in
their goals of whatever company they're
working for this has been tried with a
lot of technologies before but the
trouble is that the bar to entry is so
so much lower for something like this if
you wanted to play about with with
nuclear fission you needed a laboratory
and a whole team and someone to sell you
some fissile material yes there's a lot
if you want to play about with AI you
download something off the internet and
you've run it in the cloud and yeah
that's that's clearly not a problem
right now because if it was this would
already have happened I lost all the
folks who are saying that this is the
greatest existential threat to humanity
yeah and I see their point I'm not sure
if it's calculable I'm not sure if you
can play those odds I can see why you
would put funding towards that but I'm
also aware that there are genuine
current existential threats to humanity
like climate change and we're not
putting nearly enough towards that
either like humans are not good at
assessing those risks so I can see why
you'd want everyone to be cautious about
it i from from my uninformed perspective
I don't think it's likely but that's not
informed perspective like this is where
I say go research you know what I said
at the start go hand over to the experts
experts so I mean do you like let's say
it is possible to create a super
intelligence and then it becomes a thing
that is that is inherently something
that we're not really gonna have control
over other than you know people say well
I can't just unplug it like turn it off
but what if I just can't foresee
something that smart coming up and just
allowing you to just turn it off yeah
absolutely
um and from there it's just like it
comes down to luck whether or not they
like us or think we're in the way yeah
or more likely are completely
indifferent to us we're just ants like
oh I accidentally stepped on a few ants
no big deal I think a lot of the
conversation is unproductive because
it's like ants trying to work out how to
control humans or even to understand
humans there is a concept called a
sapiens quotient which I'm gonna mangle
here but but rough it's it's the amount
of data that an organism or something
can process okay
and once you like we can sort of have
not a conversation but we can talk to a
dog and it will understand the commands
we're giving it yeah and it will sit
down when we ask it to who've trained it
and maybe it'll be able to help us you
know we can train to help us cross the
road if we're visually impaired we can
sort of have a bit of conversation there
um you go one sapiens quotient further I
think it's a logarithmic scale so each
each quotient is ten times as much okay
yeah you go one further than that and
you end up with trying to deal with
something like a goldfish
we're cool we can put some food and it
will probably come up and get it and we
can put something there to make it a
little bit happy or not and then we go
one level further and we're dealing with
bacteria so yeah there's nothing we can
do we there's there's nothing a bacteria
could tell us or we could tell it was
like a biologic Wiccan pain yeah we can
examine it in its entirety understand
what its gonna do and track its
evolution and sequence the whole thing
nutsy steadily go down and once you're
beyond a couple of sapiens quotients
there's just and there's no meat there's
not even communication possible it's not
just that there's meaningless
communication like you saying aren't
your cute dog it's there's there's no
communication even possible a bacteria
cannot even begin to comprehend what
humans are doing right so once you start
going the other way one same thing we
are those ants we are that bacteria that
can't comprehend you guys magnitude
higher if you go once a PS quotient
further great cool you've got a computer
that can start to Shepherd us a bit and
say our sizes start to plan what we do
and organize our lives which is the the
the spoilers the end of iRobot by Isaac
Asimov yes there's the last of those
short stories is about the machines
which are the the super intelligences
that are thanks to has evolved magical
three laws um just shepherding humanity
ah and okay that's great that's one left
once you get to two and three and four
above there's nothing meaningful there
and
if you can end up with a super
intelligence I think it's more likely
that you're gonna end up with something
that just doesn't even think about us
the same way that we don't think about
the bacteria courting over us right now
right yeah I've always cuz there's the
whole like Fermi paradox right where
it's like you can't we don't know if
there's any other life out there because
we've never found it yeah so it does it
exists but I've thought like chances are
if we happen to someday find
intelligence in the universe somewhere
it's probably not gonna be a race of
species it's probably gonna be some a
single organism controlling an entire
planet and that single organism is like
the olds or the the super intelligence
the super AI that that whatever host
species created and now it's just
running everything and it's talking with
all the other singular species and so
you have like a group of these ai's
throughout the whole galaxy and it's
like they're just on such a higher plane
of existence that just doesn't mean I'm
not gonna be sending out radio signals
yeah they're not gonna want to attract a
probe with ants bleak isn't it when you
start thinking about this I I think it's
more uh I think it's more likely that
the next century is going to be a bit
better than this one like they've always
been apocalyptic scenarios have always
been you know empires falling there have
been unenlightened month before where
we've lost knowledge mm-hmm but if you
asked me to place a bet the next century
is gonna be like this one but a bit
better and only a bit better define a
bit you compare someone to the 19th
century to the 20th to the 21st yeah
each one was a bit better yes progress
in technology and communication is
increasing I would love there to be a
step change in everything like if you if
you ask me what I hope for yeah I hope
for one of those utopias to come along
it would be like yeah I hope from
magical super intelligence that will
cure death and which ends up with the
the Star Trek future I mean not even the
Star Trek future cos like there could
sir brief digression look I grew up
watching Star Trek um but it's a
universe that's fundamentally broken
okay because you because there should
have been in a world where you have a
holodeck character which can come alive
and be sentient and the ship that can
magically become sentient in one of the
episodes because the plot needed it
yeah if you have a world where they can
somehow reverse aging when plot required
via transporter yeah have a universe
that is about to break you have a
universe that has time travel and and
de-aging and everything to do with it
they should have had a singularity ten
years ago in that universe but it hasn't
happened because the plot can't allow it
to happen because you have to have 21st
century humans just in space and it's
the equivalent of someone in the 16th
century writing about the moon colony
it's great but they're not going to talk
about rocket rocket ships they going to
talk about whatever their technology was
magically displaced there would yes Star
Trek is uh-huh but here's that kind of
future where humanity has become better
where you know ideally we are all
getting along we're ideally there is one
earth and if you look at the the good
parts of that that future if you look at
humanity getting past its its worst
qualities yeah that's the sort of
utopian what I'm hoping for
do I think that's actually gonna happen
do you think it'll happen for the rich
at least I don't think that counts to
utopia there's a reason that the phrase
magical space communism keeps going
around and on that note man we talked
about a lot of stuff well is there
anything we haven't covered well I do
want to talk about your red t-shirt now
I think I kind of know the story but I
don't I don't know how many people do
you wear a red t-shirt in most of your
videos yeah I'm kind of grumpy about it
now yeah but it's a real easy time to go
through a style change change up your
wardrobe it's been a time to do that for
a decade
um but how long red shirts to you our
2020 that's all I they get ordered in
bulk every time I start getting rackety
oh so you're cycling through the yes
that's like this is your one cycle of 20
shirts I because it's easy because it
means I don't have to think about it
because it's easy for continued
because it's also cheap I could if I
want to move away from that I need to
order a load of t-shirts that all have
something I need to check on them that
all yeah that I need to make sure to
wear the same one while I'm filming the
second version of a video and no lovers
can be a problem - right
or I could transition into wearing
something that actually makes me look
like a grown-up but you know let's be
honest I'm gonna be that kind of guy in
his 30s who decides he's only gonna wear
played from now only gonna wear checked
shirts are only gonna wear life looks
like a lumberjack look that's when you
graduate from looking like a college
student you either have to get a style
or you end up just wearing like check
shirts for the rest of your life um I I
won't be looking like a college student
I can live with it so you've made a lot
haven't you know how many videos you've
made on your chance above 600 now like
bonus video stuff that's unlisted or
stuff like that but 600 a couple of
videos of yours that I really liked one
was the Hollywood sign oh yeah whole
thing about like you blurt out the
Hollywood sign because potentially they
could sue you because you're technically
making money off of a YouTube video the
chances of all that happening is really
low like for us for instance like we'll
go shoot a full-on court or video that
we are definitely gonna monetize the
entire backdrop will be the Hollywood
sign like just hypothetically speaking
obviously but like we would just do that
but the whole point of the video was
like technically you could get sued for
that
um there's all sorts of things about
First Amendment rights in the u.s. fair
use in the u.s. fair dealing in the UK
which which would play against that one
of things I actually found while
researching recently is that the u.s.
government has the Smokey Bear Act okay
you know I know smokey Smokey Bear which
is you know only you can prevent prevent
forest fires they change it's wildfires
day Wow only do Ben prevent they've
deliberately changed it because because
some forest fires are good now wildfires
are uncontrolled ones they've actually
changed the change the term without like
a [ __ ] yeah um I think that's a good
clarification so when when they put when
they invented Smokey Bear and they
commissioned it created it people
started selling ripoff Smokey Bear
motion dies but because Smokey Bear is
owned by the US government its public
domain
because anything created by an employee
of the University of the US government
is public domain okay so Congress press
the Smokey Bear Act which says that it
is a crime to use smokey bears image or
slogan for profit without the
government's permission and that's
that's not a copyright thing or a
trademark thing it is an actual federal
law on the books in this specific case
for that specific one mascot yeah um and
it's got rolled into the youthful US
Code now it's but it's still in there uh
I was gonna oh you know I could do the
the old Hollywood sign video again but
it turns out that's been challenged
because the US has the First Amendment
and any law like that that says that you
can't speak in a certain way is always
played against the Constitution and
always played against well is that a
fair thing to do so it's it's certainly
been I think ruled is fair that you
cannot make unlicensed smokey bear
merchandise because that's equivalent to
a trademark book yeah but if you want to
make a video about smokey bear yeah
they'd probably fall in the First
Amendment am I gonna do the video no
because I am a UK citizen and the idea
of the US government wanting to sue me
is frankly terrifying um but in theory
look that's a free idea like take that
someone out there do that video some
someone who's who is us and does not
mind having a legal fight with the US
government if it comes to that go for it
I'm gonna pass before we go I know
you've made so many videos that I would
love to keep talking about but there's
one aspect of your past in history that
is fast
oh boy this is worrying because there's
a lot of my past in history that I just
just don't want you were a pirate I was
a pretend pirate a pretend fire
clarification there - yeah that's more
actually out on the seas robbing people
of their booty that's more than a decade
ago now I think well like yeah what did
that mean what did that entail were you
just like walking around the street
I've run the British part of
international Talk Like a Pirate Day
back when that was a thing but back when
that was a mean before we have the word
means mm-hmm I remember when memes were
called image macros but us us I'm still
grumpy that the words check anyway
setting that aside um back back when
talk like
des was this hot new thing that people
were not really really really sick of
and let's be honest that happened really
quickly
um I handle the British bit for a while
so I was I was mad captain Tom I I had a
ponytail all down my back that became
like wild hair when I was in Paris in
characters the pirate know me talking
like this which which should not be a
realistic pirate accent it'd be a take
on someone from a Disney film many years
back but ruins your throat it absolutely
ruins your throat but for four years
every British radio station who wants to
do a thing on it would would call me up
and I would go are down there down the
microphone occasionally and it was fun
for a while and yeah I mean I I said
earlier that I got the end of University
and was ready to leave after doing the
degrees I actually didn't get to leave
for a year because at that point I had I
had already had the character for a
while I had already been doing this and
a friend of mine put my name down to be
for the student president elections
unlike Student Union president in in
England I don't about Scotland Wales
only in England is a thing where it is a
paid job for you it's not a well-paid
job but you are essentially the
interface between the student body and
the university administration okay ah
it's a horrible job don't like anyone
who's young enough to think of going for
that don't do it it's a really really
terrible job and I know that because it
backfired
like I I mean I realize this in
hindsight I pulled a Donald Trump six
years early six years early for you five
years old something like that what you
mean something starting out as a joke
and now you're having to do it I did
populism I like there were two other
candidates their supporters hated each
other they both got disqualified from I
think both from idle idling won them
terribly here certainly one of their
supporters like got banned from
campaigning because they they pulled a
trick that wasn't allowed in the in the
stair getting nasty um it was a fairly
nasty fight and and what everyone is
disillusioned that everyone anyone who
was not involved in student politics was
was disillusioned
and along comes this guy who is talking
like no one else it was not respecting
the rules of politics student politics a
high who is looking a bit ridiculous
who's just saying well this is clearly
all rubbish and silly why are we dealing
with it who occasion because he has done
a bit of research because he has the
occasion he comes up with lines that
actually do resonate accidentally I
didn't mean that
just to be clear I was not trying to win
that's not like the the brag of oh I'm
not trying to enter I genuinely was not
trying to win but the ideal result was
that I lost by one vote that would have
been really funny yeah and great and
then it would have been over but then
you won
we had single transferable vote which
means that you rank preferences are
alternative voting which says yeah okay
okay so a lot of people put me first
assuming I was going to lose and then
their choice a lot of other people voted
for there can't at first and then me
rather than none of the above
and when all the votes were tallied I
snuck a narrow victory it was the worst
year of my life but never do anything
like that um III say pulling a Donald
Trump because it was it wasn't based on
you know his policies let's let's let's
call them policies with you know let's
call of his and policies an asterisk
intonation going on there but it was it
was certainly not something I intended
or wanted to do ah but it was it was
policies like a cannon on the central
university hall just pointed at the the
university or become the Vice Chancellor
and what the equivalent is in the US but
the university admin leaders house which
which we managed the the local one the
local theatrical societies provide a
prop Kevin and we find a flag that said
boom out the end of it and that was a
great publicity stuff but all the things
like hammocks and Student Union meetings
so people could have a doze yeah did
that um
all of the sort of populist jokes yeah
some of them actually worked like we did
some yeah and in terms of actually
making people invested in student
politics yeah
turnout was was a lot higher the next
year but I wasn't good at the job like i
blundered my way through it okay I would
like to think I didn't have any major
scandals over the year but that's
because um I had a really competent team
around me who were working on their own
stuff and we traded a lot of
responsibilities okay like if I had to
go and argue something I'm not good at
going and arguing something so I would
be mysteriously unavailable that day and
someone who was really good at arguing
would go in and do that one okay um but
if it was something about getting
students interested in a thing or doing
a PR campaign or something like that
I took that so I was very much a
figurehead for a long time I at the end
of the the COS student papers love
student politics it's all the good thing
but at the end of the year when they had
the the power list the top 100 well I
was not at the top one of the folks in
my team was and that was absolutely the
correct call because he knew what he was
doing yeah and he did it I was the
figurehead and that worked out okay in
the end
because student you because a university
has like a three or four-year
institutional memory and there's not
actually that much power there anyway
I nearly turned that down so I didn't
want to do it and yeah like I've not
praised that that way before but I
basically pulled the Donald Trump
several years earlier so why the hell I
didn't see that coming I don't know well
you've managed to take that and apply it
to your own YouTube channel in making
videos wait wait water how I like being
being the figurehead you got people into
something like you I feel like you maybe
honed your skill of like oh people
aren't responding to that other thing
but they are responding to this I will
kind of pounce on that any kind of like
I feel like you took that mentality and
have you now make very interesting
videos so by doing that so the Student
Union thing like when I said I was
throwing every idea out there but I
could have turned that down I also could
have turned down the nomination when a
friend of mine put it in I could have
said ah no it's just a prank it wasn't
so because I was I was in a hostel in
Latvia when the email came in from the
Students Union saying do you want to
tell me do you want us to tell the
campus press you're running and I have
no context for this but I could have
turned that down to any point I didn't
because the alternative was not doing it
it was an idea that went out in the
alternative was not doing it so yeah
you're right in some way that but yeah
that was one more idea and it was one
more thing thrown out into the world I
ended up running because I lost a bet I
ended up running as that same character
for actual election to Parliament in the
UK unfortunately that one did lose by a
spectacular number of votes or I'm
extremely happy with that um but that
was just another idea thrown out there
and that's that's always been the
pattern bit and this what this the
advice I give anyone on creative stuff
you just keep throwing ideas out there
and hopefully one of them will work and
it might take a year and it might take a
century and hopefully one of them will
just never give up yeah unless you've
been throwing the same idea out for 10
years
they even thrown literally the same idea
out for 10 years you've got nothing back
well that's insanity yeah mate maybe the
key word is different ideas really
important key word there is different
well Tom I think that it's a good spot
to in this podcast thank you so much for
coming here and you for having me yeah
this has been great it was really
eye-opening for a lot of those topics
that we talked about
I was really surprised your take on AI
and your skepticism about it all but I
hope I'm wrong I hope we get the Utopia
well I I also hope we don't get the the
crazed yeah you know you lose a hundred
years worth of pop culture just because
nai decided to erase it from our
memories that's as bad a I scenarios go
that's pretty it's pretty reasonable
yeah well Tom here's to utopia yes and
that's it thank you so much everyone for
joining us this was a really fun
conversation big shout out to Tom Scott
for coming here and talking with us
today if you're interested in any of the
videos that we talked about in today's
podcast you can of course look Tom Scott
up on YouTube all of his videos are
there and in the meantime if you want to
stay tuned for the next episode of the
corridor cast I would recommend
subscribing on YouTube or subscribing to
any audio podcast platform you want
online and I'll see you next time bye